how surprising was it for you that pitts
ended up being the guy
i mean we all sort of figured that right
and and i think the problem
um that that happened with them and what
i found out
after the draft is that you know
they never very seriously considered
taking a quarterback and would not have
seriously considered taking a
quarterback
unless trevor lawrence was there
that was that was their guy and kyle
pitts
was graded so high on their board and
was such a universal
universally well-liked guy that all of
them
everybody from arthur blank on down and
i spent time with him
they were unanimous about this pick and
the interesting thing is
what i had heard coming out of here and
arthur blank said it to me
is that you know uh
i had written you know that i heard that
he really was interested in taking
quarterback
at one point in this process and he goes
that really wasn't the case obviously
you want a quarterback to
um you know to be in your stable for the
long term but
when they determine that they think matt
ryan
could easily outplay this current
contract where he's got three years left
and so
they were not uh they were not
aggressively going to pursue a
quarterback
the only thing that they really wished
had happened
they really wished that somebody had
come up with an aggressive trade
proposal
and it just never happened oh all right
so that's where i want to go
you know next yeah so there was never
any aggressive plays there
or anything about the number four pick
for for another team's interest in
quarterback nothing like that peter
no um you know after after the draft i
had a chance to
sit with the uh you know the new general
manager new head coach and they both
said essentially that you know we're
sort of waiting we got a bunch of calls
but they were all not very serious
uh especially because you know as i had
written last week
the market really got tamped down in the
top ten
because of how much san francisco paid
uh to go up from 12 to three
nobody was paying two ones like the
denver broncos weren't going to pay
real heavily to move up from say 9-4 and
as it turned out
it seems like they really didn't want to
do that anyway because they were all in
on
one of those two corners and they ended
up getting one of them
peter real quick because we know you got
to run julio jones you
dusted off the notion that he could be
available earlier this week now they
have kyle pitts does it make it more
likely
less likely that he's going to be traded
as of june 2.
i don't think it really i don't think it
it it matters
um you know the fact that they drafted
kyle pitts
i think mike here's what i think is
going to happen based on some
conversations in the last 24 hours
the atlanta falcons do not feel any
pressure
to trade julio jones before the end of
this draft
there's no deadline to do that if you're
not getting a pick until next year
and if he's not if there are no games
until after labor day
you know you can make a trade on july
20th
not necessarily that you will but you
could
and and just my belief is that the
atlanta falcons are not going to just
unload them for salary cap
reasons that i think they're going to be
solid on what they want
my my guess is that they want a
firm number two pick in the
uh 2022 draft i don't know that for sure
but that's that's my educated guess
if that doesn't happen scary thought
julio jones calvin ridley kyle pitts
this year with matt ryan peter thank you
so much for some of your time
safe travels and we'll talk to you again
real soon sounds great guys have a good
day see you peter
there he is peter king football morning
in america will have a full breakdown of
everything that happened at draft
weekend so you'll check that out monday
morning as you always do now
christopher what we usually do on monday
mornings during football season
superlatives of the draft edition
you have the honors your honor well i
think uh thank you very much you're so
respectful i think
the the first one that i'll go with is
just speed kills right
and i i say that because of the wide
receivers we saw that were in such a
premium in the top ten
i mean that's that's something that you
know we haven't hit on yet
i mean that was a special group of three
guys and i think the nfl told you that
they valued them as a special group of
three guys
whether it's devante smith you know
jaylen waddle
and of course jamar chase i mean to all
go in the top ten
uh you know this is pretty eye opening
it really is
and it just tells you where the league
is right now with you know the space
how well the quarterbacks throw the
football we've talked about in the past
how it's kind of like a
strikeout or home run type of league
right now it's the
nfl offenses are looking for guys who
can make big plays
and that's where you got really all
three of these receivers in the top ten
and you add in cadarius tony for the
giants in the top 20.
they're difference makers and i just
found that to be one of the cool things
of the draft altogether
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports